he is 17-year veteran the National
Football League and a good friend and a
good friend of the program
Matthew Hasselbeck how are you Matthew
what's up 18 years don't forget that
year on the practice squad blocking
Reggie White playing scout team tie down
in Green Bay was that buddy is that was
that was that was when you would get
Favre's fan mail in your locker right
Matt's not just one piece just one piece
but yes I did you know I was not getting
my own fan mail I was getting fan mail
for star players and you know fans would
say hey I don't need your autograph but
you can get this Brett Favre football
card autograph for me and send it back I
get that all the time on on Thursday
night I'm sitting there on the set
people are screaming rich rich rich and
I look up at them they're like can you
have Michael sign this for me team
player you're a team player I know even
though there's an iron-rich and Eisen
how you been
you're good everything good doing well
what's good we're great very busy
exciting NFL season a lot of injuries a
lot of new faces a lot of stars being
born people I've never heard of coming
out and having great games and you know
also with Monday Night Football just
trying to you know predict how each team
will play in these primetime matchup
some some people handle it really well
other people as it like you know for
example the Miami Dolphins they haven't
handled it well
no there's getting blown out on their
prime time games and you know someone
like Cam Newton Carolina they seem to
thrive on the attention and the energy
so it's been fun definitely fun before
we get to tonight's game though I mean
as I I started the show by saying to NFC
fans that 2016 is not walking through
that door to use the Pitino Boston
lexicon and that the Eagles and Vikings
and saints and Rams are for real but in
the AFC there's Brady again I'm
wondering again for somebody who has
played football at that position into
his 40s what is it like watching Brady
do what he's doing at age 40 matthew
negate that you know like I would say
this you know for a lot of football
players you know at every position the
you know your body slows down on you and
you know like as you get older you get
slower the quarterback position is a
little bit different in that yeah your
body might be getting slower
but the games also slowing down for you
and that's what I see in Tom Brady you
know he's never been a guy that's
necessarily relied on his running
ability or you know those types of
things and his arms always been good
enough and continues to be strong you
know I think probably the way he's
taking care of himself but he just seems
like a guy that seeing everything in
slow motion and just his command of the
huddle I mean we use the term game
managers like a very negative
connotation towards quarterbacks
sometimes but this guy is in complete
control managing every little facet that
goes on in the game and you really when
you look at the last two games the
Patriots have played he has absolutely
kill people by throwing to the running
backs and that's it you know he's
throwing the ball more downfield than he
ever has got more speed outside than he
ever has and these guys are running off
he's cocked and loaded ready to like
chuck it deep and they gotta honor it
and then what's he do he checks it down
to the running back and you know quick
counts him in the red zone I mean
everything is just just really fun to
watch yeah I know he doesn't miss a beat
he's like a cyborg when it comes to that
that any and that's Bella check too
though he's a perfect any-any weakness
that has shown either on film and the
eye in the sky that they can find and
exploit all week long and then execute
in real time they will do it and they're
spectacular at it and the thing that I
also noticed too is I mean more than
ever because he's done this before
he seems to put the ball Brady in the
exact spot that will draw a flag as well
he knows exactly where to put it Matthew
well they coach everything and you know
living in Boston now I've got it I've
got even more respect for how they do
things they work hard I'm interested to
see how they do this week though you
know they played in the altitude late
last night in Denver there's they're
going up about 2,000 feet in elevation
they're spending the week at Colorado
Springs and then they're flying to
Mexico City and having been there last
year for that - Mexico City game last
year that's that's like you know more
than 2,000 feet higher than then it is
in Denver so you know I don't know what
kind of toll that will take on their
bodies and the training of it but it's
not you're not your average you know
week for these guys for a team that's
one game at a time mentality these are
this is a team that in the past you know
a few days they've been talking about
two games at a time it's kind of new
territory for them and and how they
train you know I know I feel after you
know two weeks on the road I usually
don't feel that good I'd like to be
amongst bad but so you got that going
into it the practicing at a college and
they're uh you know dealing with
altitude it's the same time Mathew
hassle by calling in from the side of
Monday Night Football where he'll be on
the field and be of a stadium between
the Panthers and the Dolphins right here
on the Rich Eisen show what the Saints
have done is truly unbelievable right
Matthew I mean that they've they're just
a running and defensive machine and and
Brees is just just the orchestrator of
it all and then you see what keenham is
doing in Minnesota which to you do you
think of all these teams that are in
first place have the the best
opportunity in the NFC to go long here
well I mean you got you got four good
ones there you know you got the true
dimension you got Philly and you got the
LA Rams also who are playing lights out
right now but if you look at just the
Minnesota Vikings you know they've had
to overcome losing their starting
quarterback and losing their starting
tailback and they've done a tremendous
job with it but sometimes you know you
banged up like that one injury might be
too many and I look at on the flip side
in the New Orleans Saints and you know
they've been far you know far more lucky
in terms of the injury side of it and oh
by the way you've got Drew Brees
you know carrying the load at the
quarterback position so you know for me
if it's a tie I'm gonna go with Drew
Brees your hall-of-famer the guy that
can just get it done
and here's the best thing about the
weights they're winning right now
they're not asking Drew Brees to be the
guy to do it you know they're throwing
the ball maybe like 31 times a game and
getting these wins started out oh and
two they won seven in a row and they're
running the ball you can't believe the
difference maker to me obviously their
defense and special teams are playing
great but Alvin Kamara the backup
running back he's playing that Reggie
Bush role that Darren Sproles role that
you know what they hope CJ spiller would
be having him as a as a wide receiver
running running back the kind of running
back running wide receiver routes out of
the backfield he's uncover by a
linebacker in my
piñon and so you give that to Drew Brees
and Sean Payton that kind of a weapon
like they had and Reggie Bush once upon
a time that they're just gonna be really
really hard to beat well for somebody
who's seen as much film as you have and
studied collegiate Lee professionally
and now as a broadcaster Matthew and
just knowing how plays are pretty much
the same in many places and it's just
about execution and when you busted out
what Sean McVeigh is drawn up here in
Los Angeles and just give voice to just
how unique a situation it is to see
somebody not only come up with these
plays but be able to in real time and
just one half a season transform a
quarterback an entire team in LA well I
mean obviously Sean McVeigh has done an
amazing job and I think the talent was
there last year there was probably just
way too much too much dysfunction there
in LA last year I mean even Case Keenum
was the starting quarterback and
everyone's an odd case keenum can't play
you gotta get golf on the field tasty I
was doing great this year
guess what Jared Goff doing great this
year so I read that was not the problem
I think coaching and dysfunction was the
problem there last year and maybe the
transition maybe it was hard to move new
home stating all that stuff but I love
what John McVay has done he hired Wade
Phillips he said wait you take care of
the defense you know more than I do
about defense you got the defense he's
got Jon Postel gym fossil son running
special teams very very well-respected
special teams coach and he got hired he
comes in and goes alright listen I got
hired for one thing to get Jared Goff
going and to get Todd Gurley gone and
the front office is help them out they
went out and got some pieces but at the
end of the day his job is to get Jared
Goff going and I just love watching what
they do on film it's not so much the
plays that they do it's the it's the
teaching in the mindset and the
confidence that he's given this young
quarterback and you know he's saying
them he's saying to Jared Goff listen I
will never ever critique you for getting
a completion I will never say oh why'd
you throw to the short guy you have to
keep that you just get completions I'll
worry about conversions I'll worry about
third down conversions and what do you
think you see a guy throwing four over
in 350 yards and three touchdowns just
about every week so I
love the confidence that he's given
Jared Goff obviously the tools are there
but sometimes as a quarterback you need
someone in your corner that is part
cheerleader part coach part like hey you
know what I don't know what to do in
this situation but I know what my my guy
would say what was my guy say my guy
would say completion get me a completion
I will celebrate a third down completion
and then upon that's okay you know when
it's that kind of mindset that I see
Jared Goff playing with so much more
confidence than he did last year
ask Matthew Hasselbeck the poll question
long-lost Hasselbeck brother Chris
Brockman hey Matt which five and four
team in the NFC most likely to make the
playoffs
Cowboys Falcons Lions Packers or none of
the above
okay would you say Cowboys the Lions
Falcon ders Falcons out no I'm gonna go
there's only one there's a Falcons and
here's why they've only played one
division game which is unheard of they
were the last team to play a division
game in so that means that they're you
know they've got that they're you know
the destiny is kind of in front of them
it's in their hands so to speak if they
don't screw it up here at the end but
they're there the team that I think
could wake up everyone says there they
got the Super Bowl hangover no doubt
that's 100% what it is they are hungover
they probably were drunk still at the
beginning of the season but they're all
I got the Super Bowl hangover that once
they get over that I think there'll be a
dangerous team the problem is in the
meantime the Saints are two-and-oh in
the division and running away with it
but I think the Atlanta Falcons will be
my choice and then you got that team
that I bet you got there right in front
of you before I let you go Matthew I'm
sure you and Randy and Charles and the
crew and Steve Young are gonna have a
nice discussion on Cam Newton and his
maturation process and his press
conferences by the way is to press
conferences that drew the most ire from
so many people he had his best games in
the following week as you say they like
to perform in the spotlight I mean
what's your two cents on cam now this
five years into his career and his
readiness to take this team places yeah
well cam off the field in the locker
room and that's the podium very
disappointing I'll give them a demon
came on the field very impressive
he's kind of abandoned that whole idea
of like hey I gotta throw the ball first
and then run the ball second he's
running the ball
I mean he's gotten at least nine carries
in every game this month which has only
been done two other times I think in
like recent modern history and that was
Michael Vick and Tim Tebow I mean this
guy he's running the football he's
running the football and then sliding
but the quarterback lead draw read
option you know zone read all these
typical like college type offense stuff
that you saw him do it Auburn he's doing
it again he's doing it with Christian
McCaffrey the lead blocker and he's
saying hey this stadium this team feeds
off my infectious energy that could be
positive positive that could also be
negative when he's running the football
it's been very very positive so they are
they're running the ball great he's the
leading rusher on the team each and
every week they're killing it in time of
possession which is really helpful for
their defense who's number one in the
league in eight yards allowed so I think
cam will play well this year I think
he'll have a good season I think he's
got a team in position to be relevant in
February but at the same time it's gonna
look different it's not going to be cam
throwing it up to Kelvin Benjamin and
Greg Olson who obviously is still hurt
but it's going to be cam running the
ball and just kind of imposing his will
saying okay you DB's I'm gonna make you
try to tackle me take care of yourself
Matthew don't be a stranger love chat
with your best your awesome family okay
yeah thanks buddy so how do your mother
for me it's Matthew Hasselbeck the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience